save it for the party [ __ ] son of a
[ __ ] I want to keep it right here
cameras on the [ __ ] Michael bike
Michael how about this in this thing I'm
gonna introduce you rolling we're gonna
roll but I'm gonna do a little intro and
then when I say your name then you can
say whatever you want to but don't talk
until I say your name there's nothing I
can do about it come on all right you
just do you bum did you mind let's go
let's go we got towards you ready break
George get ready here we go
five five four three two
Oliver Twist that's English so welcome
to another episode of Tiger but let me
say something before I say the game now
I'm not gonna do it yet um I dare you I
love everything English I do I love
Yorkshire pudding oh wow
have you ever had have you ever had
Yorkshire pudding it's like one of the
UD the use of like angel come or
something flour really so [ __ ] good
also England has great things like Joy
Division comes from England mm-hmm Sir
Alex Ferguson comes are you city or
United United okay good Sir Alex
Ferguson comes from all the gonna
sorcerers killing it for you guys by the
way yeah I mean I'm not a massive
football fan oh you're not you're aware
of the game yeah you know who are ollie
gonna saw Sean of course alright go yeah
and as you know you tiger Billy fans you
guys know that we are gigantic UFC fans
mmm-hmm
we've been doing it since back in the
day tank Abbott yeah dancer Verne
yeah I know in my current life I have
friends like British I'm shot shame on
you
yeah yeah yeah that guy and that guy
sheep is that what you can achieve is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm gonna say that
outlet now and [ __ ] that guy really
[ __ ] breaking news and we have a very
special guest his name is Michael
Bisping give'em Rana Plaza he's a champ
be the champ be a champion no once
you're a chance I know I know you're
always a [ __ ] champ Mike hey hey I
know you don't like talking about the
fight we're not gonna do it that much
but I want to just say a couple of
things is that not only are you a champ
but you're also a journeyman right yeah
you're you're literally one of the best
guys out there you can beat anyone at
any single day well that's good yeah
there's no one that you cannot beat I
don't you're the best kind of champion
yes and you know oh my god oh I feel
sorry for him because literally
everybody I meet says that yeah must
piss him off
imagine mean the Gani other end the best
thing you ever did was knock out that
[ __ ] yeah steady on he's a nice
guy leave it out Santa Cruz escaped in
that fight you know I think what the
odds were on him right Yeah right
I was the one on the right and at the
end of the first round correct
you [ __ ] knocked him out correct yeah
I was [ __ ] amazing good yeah no I
felt good bail good I was at yeah like a
ten to one on the dog
[Music]